[Aplausos]
estavam todos muito contente aqui em
guimarães onde nasceu portugal e já
atuam no show portugal
vou a falar um carinho que pode ver aqui
uma coisa assim alto que eu sei que às
vezes a gente começa a pensar em algo
mais pois podemos pensar mas nunca
dizemos alto mas eu vou dizer
aplaude mesmo é que portugal está
preparado para dominar o mundo através
depois de 500 anos já tamos preparados
para dominar o mundo através da boa até
só para confirmar confirmaram o que é e
por quê porque agora é todas as nossas
desvantagens são vantagens quer tudo o
que é mau é bom tudo o que a gente não
tinha em bangu não tínhamos qualquer
crise foi bom passar da crise
fizemos bootstrapping começamos a
aprender é voltarmos a usar aquela nossa
talento que a gente aprende nas
universidades e nas escolas e dos nossos
pais aqui o desenlace que tudo isso
ficou mais tenso o nosso nem o tecnólogo
de zelaya voltou então o que é mau é bom
sempre que nino temos problemas pequenos
e os grandes têm grandes problemas
quem quer ser os estados unidos 2 china
índia e rússia o brasil vão resolver
esses problemas mas por agora ainda não
resolveu e executamos a resolver
já temos um carinho à frente na nossa
onda de resolver
sofremos começamos uma crise antes dos
outros
jogou muito tempo a sair apesar de já
não seríamos alguns nós anunciamos aqui
e aí é que tá a história é que a nossa
nova história começa
por 500 anos atrás a gente tínhamos
tecnologia
temos talento tínhamos positivo é muito
positivo e agora voltou a estudar também
estamos com muita tecnologia tecnologia
à nossa volta
estamos com muita lenta a nossa volta
muita credibilidade à nossa volta e
estamos positivos através e positivo
vocês não percebem o que é ser positivo
que ajuda
conseguimos campo e ganhar campeonatos
europeus conseguimos ganhar e provisões
conseguimos é ser os melhores a fazer
sapatos roupa
consegui ser o o termino cidadã a
melhorarem os nossos rankings left
conseguimos ter a maior onda do mar
chega cá conseguimos tanta coisa
positiva e isso é que é bom isso aqui
muito bom e temos que continuar
estamos a continuar porque antes eu
lembro quando eu estava aqui em portugal
vim às vezes de férias estudo parecia
que a gente criamos era de ser amigas
aqui o som bis
aqui os vampiros aquelas suas filhinhas
de papai está tudo mal
isso aqui é uma grande meta ea gente é
verdade está mal está mais mal isso aqui
nunca mais haja por terminado o governo
e agora por ver menos e menos um bis - e
menos vampiros
parece até que enfim e mudou o canal do
ok dele e estamos a começar a estar num
país positivo
estamos a começar a ver quando vem aqui
o zumbi quando é que a vampira jane voz
lá deu é só de si não precisa ouvir é o
mais ser bem positivo e é preciso ser
bem positivo porque o mundo está a mudar
há quem na choe e não sabe o que vai
fazer porque 80% no dos empregos não
existem
eu posso dizer que eu não vá ser taxista
não quer com muita mudar muito rápido
o mundo andar tão rápido
e aí está a nossa vantagem
é que portugal com o talento com a
criatividade tudo sem elástico vai
aproveitar esta onda o máximo que o
máximo é olhar para trás porque eu gosto
falar 1 30 de fato porque quando a gente
ou fax a gente acredita mas não quer ser
gente olha power cenp king no na bolsa
dos estados unidos em 2000 mudaram 50
por cento daquelas empresas mudaram as
tecnologias novas mudaram o é sempre
falando e portugal pode ser isso não
quer as empresas que foram mudadas não
eram empresas cheia de dinheiro e grande
e forte ficaram forte grandes mas
começaram em garagens muitas delas o uso
uvas o zé mazoni goggles e desapareceram
aquelas grandes pesadas cansadas e
portugal agora tem que pensar naquele
problema de sair daquela que é empresas
financeiras que custa muito por dinheiro
às vezes até fashion bancos e outras
coisas que a gente já vimos acontecer
não quer sair pauli prove que essas
tecnologias que é o verde e cosme velho
da economia azul são um dos maiores
países como eua e saímos com o mar tanto
temos tudo melhor comida incluído já
viram e isso é que é interessante é que
estamos aí agora no positivo
tínhamos aquela coisa de ser tão
positiva usa esse exemplo já várias
vezes e vou usar trabalhamos tão
positivos quando a gente ia ver a
tourada iam lá que os senhores forcados
com seu chapéu zinho e quando meus
amigos sul-africanos dois metros viam o
focada vídeos estavam com você que vai
fazer você vai apanhar um touro de lava
e eu autor ou touro o turminha com
repulsa por radar não apanhava me dizer
o que vai fazer agora é ganhar o turno e
eu os portugueses fazem isto é do otan
e quando a gravar umas sempre não
agravam a sua bateram palmas é é
sentimos que estávamos a fazer o tento
através tenta através da escolha de uma
perna mas apanhavam ea sua batiam palmas
e eu gosto ouvir isso no nosso
empreendimento tou mesmo ver anos quando
a gente olhava a explosão nove vezes a
via tem trabalhado com uma grande
empresa pois aí está o teu tempo num
estoque está mudada surtam aceitar
falhanços não aceitar risco então
aceitar representante experimentar para
vencer porque isso é como a gente
aprende a gente só aprende com a
experiência a gente só aprende por
prender falhar a sofrer muito falhar
pênalti pois qualquer tempo enfim
ganhamos um erro
é isso é mesmo isso e tendo que começar
a ser contentes das nossas pessoas que
acreditam e que são que são os melhores
do mundo
os piscianos o nosso presidente era o
melhor cozinheiro input positivo
então o primeiro que eu trazer os nossos
cozinheiros avilês nucci e nem foi tão
bom vê-la
depois os visitantes passaram por lá e
nem sabem cozinhar é tudo isso é top é
mesmo bom eu nunca vi tantas tragédias
em ser português a sério
eu vivo no estrangeiro sauna em suecos
todos que vieram para portugal estão
agora quer viver que é espetacular para
mim é tão bom porque tratam a transgene
tornando real novas idéias e eu já
estavam cansados país deus e chegaram a
equipe não um país que para os homens
estão listadas as pessoas experimentam o
que estão a dizer é eu chego aqui e vejo
o produto é tão tarde há quanto tempo eu
já tô quase portugueses dizem cerveja
durante o can é em português disse peter
klein
não há nenhum problema agora cinco
português é ter melhora cada vez que eu
viajo vai ganhar sou português e nezinho
eu conheço português berg fazem isso
também fazem aquilo também espetacular
de nossos jovens com essa atitude mas
nós jovens ainda ontem vi no acreditar
portugal 3 mil idéias 3 mil idéias que
vieram
tivemos que escolher a volta certa que
ganharam categorias diferentes e eu só
pensei permitr 2010 11 por cento dessas
idéias serem boas e andam pra frente é
130 e 10 dessas idéias exemplo só ter
0.01 tempo três grandes idéias que podem
com o mundo
estou sendo ouvido mais de mais de 10 em
comum e não é a gente pensar que estamos
a emigrar e temos que possa ser postados
unidos por não encontramos ninguém cá
esquece fazem o que têm que fazer
sei lá tem que encontrar fanning ela vem
aqui experimentam encontra fanning é k
vocês vão tocar funk bom papel só vão
para onde querem tem que fazer acontecer
fazer acontecer com vossas nevasca que a
melhor coisa por quando a gente não é
bruxo pepe parece que nunca mais ousem
pensa em fazer hits o dinheiro o termo
soturno e os portugueses não muito
português vem já com a idéia e para já
começa a vender um carinho aqui já
começamos a entrar algum dinheiro nunca
vai existir os outros os portugueses
agora a mandarem mais em miles estão a
mandar mais em mãos tentam abrir o
network deus estão aí pra fora então ir
a feiras não após produto online mas
pensavam em vender lisboa porto e do
porto e lisboa é tão difícil é ter
alguém gosta do benfica ea pessoa do
porto gosta de esgoto está difícil
vender tem que mandar lá ninguém
pergunta qual é o teu clube ninguém eu
nunca fui perguntado então perceber tem
que pensar liga beijar na hora que fizer
isso vamos ter aqui um país
vai ser bom para nós
mas vai ser muito melhor para os nossos
filhos nossos médios mas muito muito
melhor e isso é que é mesmo importante é
que esses tablets para mim é gente saber
quando a gente fazer as crianças que
elas vão também fx as crianças mas é
melhor saber que elas não estavam em pé
para mim é muito importante eu quase
transmitir que duas português que o
encontro
vocês não têm nada a gente porque também
sou primeiro né
não estamos nada atrás ninguém ok muitas
coisas estamos bem à frente a gente já
vê os problemas ainda hoje ouvimos é da
nossa educação que tem que começar a
mudar porque o futuro vai ser feito de
pessoas criativas e se eu não tenho
nenhuma dúvida
eu acredito 100% isso eu acredito se
quiser robots e pessoas que fazem tudo
certinho estudo a outros grandes países
com milhões de pessoas fazem isso mas a
gente quer ligas e queremos pessoas que
conseguem levar os robots e fazerem
grandes coisas com os robots as pessoas
que ensinam e fazem tudo certinho
a gente precisa de portugueses criativos
que estava em falar com o mundo como a
gente fez 500 anos atrás onde sabemos
fazer pax recebíamos com de mapas e
sabiam sobre as coisas que fazia mpt
vantagens e mudar o mundo dessa maneira
porque você não fizer isso é que muita
meu irmão porque eu não tou a ver
líderes de um sítio no mundo saírem está
mesmo difícil e ateus linhas que saem
não tão nem aí pra isso que dá pra mudar
tem que fazer o que os eleitores
escolheram tem que fazer e isso é muito
difícil a gente estamos a ver isso em
todo o sítio
eu acho também que os portugueses estão
com uma grande vantagem de começarem por
jovens a entrar para dentro de cargos de
líder por muitas vezes velhos alguns
morreram estão na prisão aconteceu o que
aconteceu agora é bom ter pode entrar
sair de novo
e essa novo vai começar a dizer as
coisas condição com tem que ser como eu
sentem como é que vão ter paixão se as
coisas mudarem esse as coisas mudam pan
pra que lado de dede a gente acreditar
ainda vai ser mais rápido porque tem
gente tem que aproveitar porque as ondas
são boas depois almargem ea gente não
precisa de aprender não precisa ter
outra crise para aprender outra vez eu
acho que temos que lembrar dessas coisas
mas o que é que eu queria dizer é que
também é um dos poucos mais lindo que já
vi
agora estava proibida tão souza isso mas
é verdade é assim é como tudo na vida
portugal passou experiências difíceis
nossos empreendedores em 2 ouvimos
passaram experiências difíceis
foi a nossa família passaram um período
muito difícil na vida também sempre a
sair coisas difíceis e eu tenho uma
expulsão passou as que querem perceber
como é que a gente passa os períodos
difíceis eu já disse isso antes
quem não gostar de ouvir alguma coisa
sobre a gasolina é melhor fechar em us
voz ao vídeo
porque a verdade é mesmo isso na vida a
gente tem que olhar para frente
na vida quando as coisas correm mal com
sócios com empregados com clientes com
família com namorados com esposas
temos que esquecer e andar para frente a
olhar para o futuro e não olhar para
trás porque só o futuro a gente consegue
dar para trás já aconteceu e é por isso
que eu digo a todos todos todos que
acham que é que querem aprender mais
rápido da próxima vez tiverem
dificuldades é que o que tem que fazer é
comprar um jardim rosina porque é muito
importante porque só com gasolina é que
quando exemplo vamos no rabo é que
andamos para a frente mais rápido não
dói tanto ok
isso é muito importante porque não temos
gasolina dói tanto que nunca mais
olhamos para frente vamos sentar e
explicar e explicar a todos e todos têm
que ouvir como é que foi tão mal mas só
fui tão mal nuclear pois tu tá mal
depois às vezes quando era tarde já não
olha para frente e fazemos através e
quando fazenda também é porque estamos
lá no cu
então tem que mesmo pensar bem e dizerem
a gente concorda mal é despachar para
frente e não olhar para trás não quer
pôr de momento é nossa grande vantagem
do momento é com muito estava no kur
representamos aqui com cara de sorte nem
sabemos como uma estrela no meio do
mundo turfa menu maio leva isso com é
souza quatro horas e meia
nova iorque duas horas de lisboa do
demônios e paris
estamos aqui todos os dias e eu noutro
dia tentava ver a coreia do sul ea do
norte desculpa tem aqui os mísseis
depois tinha assim aqui coréia do norte
e por tinha o primeiro míssel chegar
aqui o outro missão chega aqui uma
comissão chega estados unidos e passa a
frança ou o maior chegou estados unidos
e chega assim quase tocar em portugal
mas não toca
o incrível é incrível
ok é tão já que sabemos que não vamos lá
com o mixto no cu é começar a trabalhar
e andar para frente ea verdade é essa
que não nós só fizeram um caminho mais
ter o nosso pib quer que a r 1.500
conseguir todos trabalhar mais 10% por
ano
imagino que esse país vai crescer e
imagino que a gente vai ser
imagina é a rapidez que a gente vai
tomar o mundo
então pra mim o jogo estava dizendo a
todos trabalhem experimentou não tem
time falhar porque eu não emprego
ninguém que não falhou
então por que eu já vi que não
experimentou e que vai falhar comigo
porque eu vou dizer eu vou experimentar
então muito obrigado a todos muito
obrigado a guimarães o utente ea força
pra frente o que é real
[Aplausos]